il trouve toujours des gens incroyables
déjà trouvé un type ont rappelé terrasse
bull bof et c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle entre nous qui va être
extraordinaire mais un petit peu parce
qu'il a dans sa région un joli pierre
ouais moi quand je suis allé le voir la
veille du jour où j'ai je les filme et
il m'a dit je veux bien vous répondre à
toutes vos questions mais à une seule
condition c'est que vous veniez de
bouteilles de vin alors je suis allé
chercher un petit vin jeu et puis j'ai
acheté un petit vin du coin je sais pas
quoi 34 francs 20 alors je m
vous aimez chanter roussillon non je
n'ai pas goûté le bon vin pas cher ça
n'existe pas je vais apporter un mauvais
voilà cher mais ça lui a plu quand même
parce qu'il a vu les deux les deux
bouteilles pendant que lui poser des
questions
et donc voilà voire extrêmes là qu'est
ce qui fait alors cet homme là bas je
vais pas vous le dire justement mais il
a il a vécu il a gagné sa vie d'une
drôle de façon et ça je vous le dis je
crois la deuxième phrase du sujet le
plus abordé le sujet c'est d'arriver à
ryad dans les pyrénées-orientales
j'ai rencontré un type qui a gagné sa
vie d'une drôle de façon
il était contrebandiers en plumes parce
qu'en espagne c'est est moins cher toute
sa vie il a passé la frontière française
en fraude avec des enclumes 200 kg sur
son dos une belle santé qui l'avaient
monsieur bora une belle santé qui dit
devoir aux petites piques est de vin
rouge qui coûte ici comme des rivières
[Applaudissements]
au point de pouvoir traverser les
pyrénées avec une enclume
oui monsieur qui ronge avait porté à
acquérir aux voiliers non seulement
c'est lourd mais ça doit faire mal aller
pour lui donc l'uimm les clubs c'était
de voir la portée d'un seul coup ce
n'est pas le voyez vous ne répondez pas
que des fois ça va l'attraper il faut
savoir la plainte neuchâtel face quelle
façon enfin la commanderie
s'cusez moi le jeu par les chiens et
deux maîtres par le trognon et ont même
été jusqu'à l'épaule gauche tu as
toujours les ponts de gauche à droite je
ne pouvais pas c'était chaud mais pour
le brochet quelle santé oui oui la santé
je vais eu
non je me de l'avis du bagne lola une
flou al aulaqi chaud une nuit alors que
monsieur bourg a traversé les pyrénées
avec une enclume sur le doubs il a
rencontré un sanglier qui allait bien
car j'ai vu le match semble au mieux les
chemins et sa mouche et complet je me
suis approché du chemin et c'est alors
que j'ai du style et la forme le 20
juillet alors qu'ils avaient bouffé les
imiter
joint ce grenier maréchal juillet à fait
comment voyez alors pourquoi vouliez
n'est pas foutu l'enclume sur la gueule
je suis pas chasseur je n'aime pas ma
tactile et d enfin quand vous arriviez
chez un paysan français avec une enclume
sur le dos que lui disiez vous jamais
les douaniers vous ont attrapé jamais
vous n'avez eu d'ennuis aux mamies
infligea ça c'est surtout les grands
dealers tous les gros trafiquants
doivent être punis honte sur vous
monsieur bourrin les bravo quand même
pour le bel effort
king chine n'achète pas comment vous
faites mais trouver un trafic au nom
crime y ait pas trafiquant de locomotive
d'armoire normande et altère tient
trafiko d'alter infi candel terre un
type qui porterait des haltères sur son
dos ouais les et les renseigne tipi pour
il pourrait faire des maternelles
éventuellement il pouvait faire des
compètes et tous voilà qui voit là bas
fait vachement costaud et qui ne décolle
oui la venue avait pas demandé à l'amf
de paix pour transporter ses envies et
de président à man
[Musique]